[Musica]
comincio con una domanda Quanti di voi
oggi non si sono mai Guardati allo
specchio
nessuna mano alzata
prevedibilissimo perché quell'oggetto è
un oggetto Incredibile è un oggetto nel
quale ci Riflettiamo e sul quale
troviamo delle risposte
aggiustare un rossetto aggiustare una
cravatta
sistemarsi i capelli
è importantissimo per noi ma non perché
siamo vanitosi Ma perché abbiamo un
assoluto bisogno di sapere cosa l'altro
vede di noi è l'unico modo è lo specchio
però
quando siamo davanti a uno specchio noi
non pensiamo che abbiamo in realtà una
capacità cognitiva incredibile ed è
quella di capire che chi vediamo nella
superficie riflettente siamo noi stessi
lo diamo per scontato è normale Ma
guardate non lo è affatto non lo è
affatto perché fino a che non arriviamo
avere due anni di età noi non abbiamo
questa capacità i bambini di un anno non
sono capaci di riconoscersi allo
specchio riconoscono altri oggetti la
faccia della mamma riflessa quando sono
davanti allo specchio ma non vedono se
stessi O meglio non riconoscono se
stessi
Abbiamo due modi di rivedere noi stessi
uno è attraverso uno specchio e uno è
attraverso la faccia dell'altro che si
riflette nella nostra
ora per chi studia gli animali e cerca
di capire se le regole che valgono per
l'uomo
valgono anche per gli altri animali
perché anche noi siamo animali Beh
Dobbiamo riuscire ad escogitare dei
sistemi perché Certo un cavallo non tira
mai se è abile a riconoscersi in uno
specchio quindi sta a noi cercare le
risposte nella testa del cavallo come
facciamo per capirlo
utilizziamo quello che viene nominato e
ormai collaudato da tanti scienziati
come il Mark test semplicemente basta
mettere una punta di colore in una zona
del corpo che non è altrimenti visibile
Se no Al soggetto stesso chiaramente se
non con l'uso di una superficie
riflettente e vedere che cosa fa
l'animale
non è semplice non è semplice perché
finché si tratta dell'uomo è abbastanza
immediato Ma quando abbiamo a che fare
con animali che hanno magari e vivono i
mondi sensoriali diversi non è sempre
così scontato Noi l'abbiamo fatto col
cavallo Il cavallo è un animale
intelligente anche se mangia solo l'erba
ma intelligentissimo vive in un
complesso sistema sociale dove a
essenziale capire le relazioni che gli
altri individui hanno con se stessi e
tra di loro
e lo abbiamo fatto prendendo il cavallo
e mettendolo davanti a uno specchio
ovviamente utilizzando come tutta la
buona scienza vuole una situazione di
controllo che è semplicemente quella di
mettere il colore nello sperimentale e
togliere il colore ma lasciare la
sensazione tattile per il controllo
e questo è quello che abbiamo trovato
lui è Ercole un animale incredibile
bellissimo
quella che vedete è una piccola
telecamera infilata dentro lo specchio
Ecco che si guarda sapete che i cavalli
hanno una visione laterale estremamente
sviluppata Si scrolla ma non è
sufficiente Allora si pulisce
riesce anche a togliersi parte della
marcatura Dopodiché Beh c'è la necessità
di ricontrollare se il lavoro è stato
ben fatto Ed eccoci qua Pensate se
avesse avuto le dita cosa avrebbe E cosa
sarebbe riuscito a fare
abbiamo detto però che lo specchio non è
l'unica superficie sulla quale noi ci
possiamo riflettere le facce degli altri
sono importanti per noi sono importanti
per noi e per gli altri perché capire le
emozioni altrui passa dalla faccia non
passa da una complicata teoria della
mente che molti ascrivono soltanto
all'uomo quando in realtà ormai anche
questa teoria un po' obsoleta comincia a
scricchiolare ma guardare la faccia
degli altri è come vedere se stessi ed è
questo che ci mette in contatto col
mondo
prenderemo come primo esempio un
comportamento di una banalità assoluta
una cosa che facciamo sempre la sera
prima di addormentarci e facciamo sempre
la mattina nel momento in cui ci
svegliamo che è sbadigliare
Moravia nella sua Romana scriveva che la
storia dell'umanità non è che un lungo
sbadiglio di noia Permettetemi di dire
che è una delle più
semplicistiche visioni di questo
comportamento semplice
sbadigliare è importantissimo
sbadigliare ci permette di cambiare le
azioni motorie sbadiglio per stress
sbadiglio per fame sbadiglio per sonno
sbadiglio perché voglio mantenere un
certo livello di attenzione e non mi
meraviglierò se qualcuno di voi nei
prossimi 2-3 minuti di questa Talk
comincerà a sbadigliare perché lo
sbadiglio è contagioso io sbadiglio e
nella grande percentuale dei casi
qualcuno davanti a me comincerà a fare
la stessa cosa Siamo a cena tutti
insieme un sabato sera la settimana di
lavoro Finalmente ci troviamo con gli
amici
le 11:30 mezzanotte dopo magari qualche
abbondante bicchiere di vino o qualche
Insomma magari antipasto un po'
particolarmente ricco e pesante il primo
comincia a sbadigliare all'inizio cerca
di nasconderlo con la mano stringendo le
mandibole ma non ce la fai e sbadiglia
o dopo
a fare la stessa cosa e poi ancora un
altro e poi ancora un altro con un
effetto Domino irrefrenabile
qualcuno si alza e dice Beh ragazzi s'è
fatta una certa dobbiamo andare perché
le facce lo dicono
Ecco che in quel momento attraverso quel
semplice comportamento riflesso sulla
faccia dell'altro si trova
incredibilmente un accordo si alzano
tutti Ciao Allora il cappotto Dov'è la
borsa in salotto Ok Vado via Ciao Ci si
vede
si fa qualcosa insieme
Allora la domanda è anche qui ma questa
capacità è solo nostra allora ci siamo
divertiti veramente abbiamo preso un
aereo Siamo volati in Sudafrica e
abbiamo studiato una delle specie più
iconiche del mondo animale il re della
foresta che poi foresta non c'è mai ma
insomma va bene lo stesso e Ed ecco che
abbiamo cercato di studiare questa cosa
questo è sono tre soggetti in realtà
sono quattro perché è nascosto qua ce
n'è un altro e questo è uno dei nostri
Pride un gruppo di quelli che abbiamo
studiato per sei mesi
seguendoli nella savana filmando tutto
quello che si poteva filmare Avete visto
il primo sbadiglio del soggetto a
sinistra Qui ci troviamo e nella riserva
del macali appunto in Sudafrica e vedete
che il secondo animale risponde allo
sbadiglio del primo questo Attenzione
Non sta dormendo È in una situazione di
dormiveglia ha visto perfettamente cosa
stava accadendo agli altri due ma non è
un problema suo
se vediamo che qui c'è di nuovo un altro
tentativo un altro mezzo sbadiglio e
quindi c'è questo effetto Domino
Dopodiché il primo sbadigliatore
chiamiamolo così si alza
e dopo poco dopo aver fatto il suo terzo
sbadiglio si alza anche colui che aveva
risposto si alza lo specchio del primo e
fanno qualcosa insieme
ora questa video potrebbe non voler dire
nulla se non che di questi esempi ne
abbiamo accumulati tantissimi attraverso
le solite classiche noiosissime analisi
statistiche abbiamo trovato che Boh
guarda un po' se io rispondo allo
sbadiglio dell'altro Faccio più o meno
la stessa cosa ma se non rispondo No sto
lì e faccio i fatti miei Ecco che un
semplice comportamento stupido banale
serve da miccia per creare coesione
gli animali questi leoni sono
estremamente coesi cacciano insieme
curano insieme la prole difendono
insieme un territorio Quindi la
sincronizzazione motoria è fondamentale
esattamente come la stessa
sincronizzazione motoria quando noi alla
fine della scena diciamo Ok allora di
andare a letto
c'è un altro esempio
in cui è importantissimo
rispecchiarsi nella faccia dell'altro ed
è quello del ridere insieme Avete mai
visto quelle vecchie sitcom degli anni
70 quando molto stupide e quando a un
certo punto nel momento della nel
momento dell'esaltazione massima della
battuta più importante del telefilm
partono le risate e questo dovrebbe in
teoria in teoria stimolare lo spettatore
a ridere
Beh si ride quando si gioca si ride
quando si prova una sensazione di gioia
si ride anche insieme agli altri e il
modo di condividere questa Gioia è
ridere insieme agli altri ma giocare Non
è il solo contesto in cui ci divertiamo
il sesso
Beh il sesso è fondamentale senza il
sesso non ci ha evoluzione
nessuno di noi sarebbe qui Se non ci
fosse il sesso la cosa interessante
è che noi ci siamo divertiti a studiarlo
in questa specie qualcuno di voi
eccezion fatta ai miei studenti per
favore non intervenire Qualcuno conosce
questa specie
qualcuno la conosce non siate Timidi
dai i bonobo i bonobo Cos'è un bonobo
specie sorella dello scimpanzé che più o
meno conoscerete tutti immagino No beh
contrariamente allo scimpanzè il bonobo
è molto Libertino e per Libertino
intendo Libertino l'avete in mente
un'immagine del kamasutra Ecco quello è
il bonobo il bonobo inventa il sesso in
tutti i possibili modi immaginabili ed è
per questo che è stata eletta la specie
che rappresenta il gruppo di pensiero
hippie negli anni 60 70 Fate l'amore non
fate la guerra era il motto utilizzato
dal gruppo IP da corrente filosofica
hippie e il bonobo era la specie
delezione perché
perché il bonobo fa del sesso un mattone
sociale
maschi con maschi femmine con femmine i
piccoli che si intrufolano con tutte le
parti
etero contatti eterosessuali
accoppiamenti al di fuori del periodo
riproduttivo quindi c'era la società del
bonobo è pervasa da questo comportamento
sono anche molto giocosi peraltro e
giocano da adulti Esattamente come la
nostra specie Allora noi abbiamo
cominciato a cercare di capire ma
cosa succede nel momento del contatto
sessuale soprattutto tra le femmine
Perché le femmine perché dovete capire
che a differenza della specie sorella
questa in questa specie sono le femmine
che dominano i maschi
anche se queste femmine non sono
imparentate tra di loro
E cosa succede attraverso i contatti
homosex le femmine creano dei legami
forti
indissolubili di supporto nel momento in
cui un maschio tenta di aggredire una
femmina non si trova solo una femmina
davanti ma se le Trova tutte contro
questo perché sono in grado di fornire
supporto alle altre femmine attraverso
la creazione di legami sociali che sono
incredibilmente forti e questo permette
a queste femmine di dominare su tutti i
maschi
allora Ma cosa succede durante un
contatto sessuale femminile
succede questo
quanto più le espressioni facciali
rispecchiano e risuonano nella faccia
dell'altro notare questo piccolo che
tenta disperatamente di trovare qualche
soluzione queste facce queste facce sono
estremamente importanti perché più le
due femmine si guardano negli occhi e
più una risponde al sorriso dell'altra
Ed ecco che le interazioni sessuali
raddoppiano o triplicano in durata
alle femmine piace alle femmine piace
non soltanto fare sesso alle femmine
piace guardarsi negli occhi e rispondere
l'una all'altra per fare in modo che
quel momento magico duri di più
Beh come qualsiasi biologo evoluzionista
La domanda è
Ma perché Che c'entra tutta questa
storia di mimica facciale con
l'evoluzione Quali sono i vantaggi dello
specchio perché un carattere di
rispondenza motoria e di condivisione
facciale è stato premiato
dall'evoluzione
Ok prendiamo il caso che Margherita che
è qui in prima fila sia una femmina
giovane di bonobo che sta lasciando il
suo gruppo Natale per evitare problemi
di reincrocio e tentando di entrare nel
mio gruppo dove io essendo abbastanza in
su con l'età rappresenta la matriarca
Margherita verrà da me e mi inviterà a
questi a queste orge sessuali Io
accetterò perché una buona matriarca
deve mantenere i rapporti sociali con
tutto il gruppo Ed ecco che Margherita
comincerà a entrare nelle Grazie di
questa vecchia matriarca i primi
contatti sessuali che Margherita avrà
con Elisabetta sono costellati di questo
scambio di sguardi e di questa
condivisione di risate Questo farà sì
che tra Margherita e Elisabetta i
contatti sessuali siano più prolungati e
che l'una cerchi l'altra perché c'è
quello che si chiama rewording positivo
cioè una soddisfazione di tipo positivo
questo nel breve termine nel medio
termine Margherita di Elisabetta
svilupperanno un'amicizia cominceranno a
grumarsi a pulirsi il pelo più spesso
cominceranno a giocare insieme e per gli
altri membri del gruppo sarà chiaro che
questa è una relazione preferenziale
ben presto Quando Margherita o
Elisabetta avranno bisogno dell'aiuto
l'uno dell'altra con l'altro sia luna
che l'altra correranno Quindi se
Elisabetta sarà aggredita da un maschio
Margherita correrà ad aiutarla
Elisabetta farà altrettanto questo che
cosa implica implica lo sviluppo della
Cooperazione nel lungo termine
ma cooperare vuol dire ottenere più
risorse vuol dire mantenere sotto i
maschi avere la priorità di accesso al
cibo Elisabetta e Margherita magari si
aiuteranno anche nell'allevamento dei
piccoli Ecco che quindi il lavoro viene
diviso viene distribuito Si risparmiano
energie e si Acquisiscono risorse Ecco
che quindi Elisabetta e Margherita
avranno più figli che arriveranno alla
maturità sessuale e quindi la fitness il
potenziale riproduttivo di Elisabetta e
Margherita aumenterà Ma siccome
Elisabetta e Margherita sono bravissime
nel guardarsi negli occhi e Nello
scambiarsi queste risate avendo più
figli questo carattere rimarrà nella
popolazione
ed ecco così
che potremmo dire che l'evoluzione ci
mette la faccia ma soltanto se c'è uno
specchio davanti Grazie